hi everyone James Gunn here co-ceo of DC
Studio I'm excited to announce the new
slate of DC projects it's an exciting
time we're excited to show it to you
we're calling this phase chapter one
we're trying guys we're really trying it
here just
just give us one more chance please
unlike before this is going to be a new
DC EU with a new plan mainly that there
is one now but first up we've got some
housekeeping to take care of you know
Shazam 2 Aquaman 2 you know oh The Flash
The Flash surprisingly good I know we're
just as surprised as you probably are we
also have a section of the DC Universe
called that other stuff projects that
don't really fit the brand but make us a
lot of money so we're still going to
make it but let's get to the stuff
you've all been waiting for uh what is
it going to be a Justice League
something crazy you guessed it a
surprisingly selective and interesting
side of superhero stories that have not
been told to death
yeah and Superman